hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to I am bread okay I
know what you're thinking I know what
you're thinking I said I said that I
would never ever ever ever ever ever
ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever
ever play this game again but okay okay
but I didn't know I didn't know that you
could play with a gamepad I said this on
a livestream I didn't know because I
didn't know because surgeon simulator
was played through the keyboard and this
is made by the developers of certain
simulators so how would I assume that I
didn't need to use a keyboard when the
original game that they made before was
supposed to be hard with a keyboard I
didn't know that in splitting bill a
blade with a gamepad you didn't say that
it was recommended for you with the game
plan so I don't know I'm okay whatever
alright so I'm gonna play it again I'm
gonna give it a fair play I'm gonna
really really really go for it this time
but I am under a lot good god that was
loud I am under a lot of stress okay so
okay for some reason I'm not out that is
really loud in my ears why is it so loud
it's loud okay good loud it was not the
music in the menu is not that loud ow my
ears okay so I turned it down a little
bit good golly Miss Molly okay so oh how
is this any easier than what it was
before
I didn't even jam myself up okay that's
alright
Oh kid okey then still getting used to
this sorry did I Jam myself at all I
didn't Jam on me get this laid out of
the way
no no
okay okay so good god how is this
supposed to be easier okay well alright
then this is just a bunch of all good
god a bunch of bull though we go we go
edibility is a little low and we're
getting a little crumbly but that's okay
because I'm gonna say that we're gonna
go holy [ __ ] this is still hard holy
balls this isn't an easier keyboard is
not any worse you all suck dong you all
suck dong I'm on the thing let's just
[ __ ] go and then we'll get home today
and I'll play myself a little game of
god god dammit well at least I got some
ants on me that'll add a little protein
protein okay come on come on come on no
no no just what is even happening
okay I'm gonna calmly approach this
screw I'm on a long way because this
doesn't make any goddamn sense okay here
we go screw head ability I'm just going
for time here why is the camera turning
why is the camera turning just go up oh
god I'm at a grip god damn this stupid
piece of [ __ ] game I hate it so much why
is it here we go just get in the thing I
don't care I'm out of time
I've had a very stressful day I'm on a
schedule just get Frick up top just get
up there just get up there okay what in
goddamn hell do you want from me game
huh
[Music]
ah okay okay I'm toast
I gotta see okay all right everyone is
so proud of me
everyone's so happy for me so proud okay
we need to carry on here because we got
like no time so how do I I gotta give us
some mouse it really does want you to
use the keyboard and mouse you know and
I did actually better okay dr. mr.
Merton was very distressed throughout
the session he arrived earlier claiming
that his house had been broken into but
there was no signs of forced entry in
the assailant Aloha been in the kitchen
and I reported it to the police says he
believes council we're tormenting him
and the police would be on in on it
it took three subtle hints that is 60
minutes were up before mr. Burton ended
the session
hey I invited mr. Burton clears head in
his kitchen specifically moving things
into the lounge hopefully this will
trigger his memory this is a very
worrying development clearly it cannot
recall the incident as kitchen I will
reveal the diagnosis with Louise and
perhaps later appropriate medication and
lettuce have scheduled another session
for tomorrow okay then so this guy's
going a little crazy because his bread
is alive and everything's good okay so
all right what do we got going on here
uh floor looks awfully dirty I'm gonna
take a calm and collected approach to
this now that I actually know how to
play except that some goddamn reason
okay nothing about this game is meant to
be good in any way nothing about this
game is meant to be fun this game is not
supposed to be fun
screw everything about this game and in
fact I hate oh okay got it
tell man hang this in everyone there we
go
damn it grep the son of a [ __ ] crap
there another sock I did it I went up on
a thing and I thought a thing okay
whatever I need to go this way
it is I went immediately from hating the
keyboard controls to hating the gamepad
controls it didn't get battery to die
there we go on a plate son of a [ __ ] I
broke that I'll pay for that I'm gonna
pay for that I'm gonna pay for all that
I'm gonna pay for all this later when I
have a stroke god damn you
where am I even trying to go here okay
what was the point of this nothing there
was no point I was not supposed to go
here Oh God not what I know it's a piece
of [ __ ] game I'm already strong really
no friend me no okay camera can you just
please cooperate with me for two seconds
so that I can just oh god I hate
everything about this game I seriously
only have hate for this game come on
okay left lumber swing right trigger
okay there we go okay where am I going
God don't what a wits where you going
god dammit why why why ate everything I
freaking hate everything if anyone
thinks then I'm not really really angry
where do I go whoa whoa whoa the hell
oh god damn everything in this case go
go go go go go
could have gone up the other side of you
it would have been a lot easier wouldn't
it just okay just okay just okay okay
okay
I am so unbelievably not okay with this
game it's I don't even care how much
people say that this game is good and
fun all right then Oh become toast I
hate life and everything about it oh god
I hate it why why why why why why okay
yay cowbell okay then all right this is
fine that's fine that's fine okay I seem
to be getting good at this game not that
I ever wanted to be good at this game
but I seem to be getting at least a
little better tonight
[Music]
nothing has ever produced more real
anger out of me nothing in my entire
goddamn life
I'm already strive been through a very
stressful day if you could just
cooperate with a no of course won't why
would it it wasn't this potted plant
it's gonna get in my freakin way it's
gonna lose my grip enough so I won't be
able to get over mr. Brad managed to
become toast
powdered toast man before he truly
became the superhero and Ren and Stimpy
that he deserved to be also dis it's a
bunch of poopy a sticks am I going over
there there's an ironing board is there
gonna be an iron now no no no what the
[ __ ] long way to climb
oh no you piece oh my god are you
kidding me are you kidding me Zach oh
god oh god such a bad god oh no oh no
come on
[ __ ] [ __ ] it
God [ __ ] it I don't I don't care I
really don't care I just don't I don't
want to play this anymore
[Music]
I can't play this game I cannot play
this game because the controls and how
they don't cooperate with me
Kirk's me in such a way that it's
uncontrollable anger I I'm not joking to
say this game has made me more angry
than I ever have been in my entire life
I can't play this game anymore
I cannot do it anymore I will not play
it anymore
if you wish my sanity to stay intact you
won't ask me to play it ever ever again
because I can't do this so thank you
everyone for watching up to this point
the gamepad didn't make it any damn
better I'm done you're done
we're done bread's done let's get some
toast the things en and as always I'll
see you in the next video
[Applause]
[Music]
they're British they're more like flying
squirrel kungfu Sal no sumo I've ever
been to stand up against BAE